u.s president joe biden is to announce
that the united states will double its
global donation of kofi 19 shots aiming
to vaccinate 70 of the world's
population within a year the new
commitment would see an additional 500
million doses donated to the un's kovacs
program mr biden is to host a covid19
summit of world leaders on the sidelines
of the un general assembly about doing
more to curb the pandemic and
encouraging the global recovery
well since the pandemic began more than
220 million people have been infected
with the novel coronavirus resulting in
more than 4.6 million deaths around 31
of the world's population have now been
fully vaccinated with the vast majority
of those in high income countries
the pandemic has cost an unprecedented
number of people their jobs in 2020
around 252 million jobs disappeared and
so far this year only about half of
those have returned
women migrant workers and young people
have been worst affected
young people also missed out on
education each losing an average of 74
learning days last year that's a third
of a school year with students in
low-income countries losing even more
well the key to ending the pandemic of
course lies in vaccinations on tuesday
u.n secretary general antonio gutierrez
described the unequal distribution of
vaccines as an obscenity
the situations in countries around the
world of course is vastly different
for millions around the world life is
back to something like normal
50 000 at a concert in denmark
really what corona
easy to say in a country where 80
percent of people are vaccinated
the scene in afghanistan couldn't be
more different
this desperate man one of many
critically ill
alive only with the help of a fast
diminishing supply of drugs oxygen and
faith
our country is a poor country
we need medicine
different things almost everything
if someone will come and give us
something
and the patient's problems will be
resolved with allah's mercy
this is what i ask for
quite how bad things are is impossible
to know as testing here is almost
non-existent
in togo these people are lining up to
protect themselves after the government
introduced a
pass system which only allows vaccinated
people into certain places
yes if we had not done this i really
wasn't thinking of getting vaccinated
persuading people is only half the
battle when there are just 1.6 million
doses for eight million people
here at rio de janeiro's remembrance
forest they're planting trees for the
dead
it's in memory of my husband who died of
covid in march of last year
it's hard to talk about education
even after half a million lives lost
brazil continues to be a hot spot
just 50 percent of the population have
been vaccinated
in part because of skepticism fueled by
president bolsonaro including this
awkward exchange with the british prime
minister recently
which underlined just how difficult
orchestrating a global response to covet
19 can be
but as the cameras are shuffled out the
brazilian wags his finger in protest
not yet he says
well let's consider the global response
with that candice sahoma she's an
advocacy officer with the med sound soft
frontier access campaign in south africa
she joins us from
johannesburg welcome to dw um let's talk
about the the kovacs program which was
set up by the un to ensure equitable
distribution of vaccines to poorer
countries with richer countries pledging
money and vaccine doses so given that it
is up and operating why is it that
large proportions of the world's poorest
countries are still unvaccinated
um thank you so much for having me on
your show i think
it's a good question
and currently what we're seeing is that
there's a global imbalance in the
current vaccination rollout we're
currently seeing large numbers of
vaccinated populations in the global
north because those countries have
stockpiled vaccines leaving lower and
middle-income countries scrambling and
even you know mechanisms like the
corporate facilities even scrambling
because they cannot um because you know
the large or rather the high income
country um
countries have actually stockpiled um
vaccines and i think what we're seeing
is that you know there's some uh you
know comments and opinions that you know
there's a
hesitancy issues of hesitancy and that's
why we have low level you know rates of
vaccinated people in in africa and lower
the middle income countries but
truly we also have seen studies that
have shown that there's low levels of
hesitancy in these situated in these
countries but actually there is a um an
issue of supply and getting access to
the to these vaccines and which is
actually a problem and really makes you
question the current you know approach
in terms of so just to be absolutely
clear
um you've talked about the stockpiling
in the richer countries does that mean
that the fact that the kovacs program is
short of vaccines to distribute because
if it isn't then that's not a reason for
those countries to be short of vaccine
if you understand me
yeah so there is it is an issue of you
know um uh
the corvex facility not being able to to
access vaccines you know there is
obviously resources to buy this vaccine
but we have seen how you know um uh
countries like your the u.s the eu
stockpiling and there has been some
campaigns running you know trying to get
and encourage these camp um um countries
to donate
sorry you you we we heard that so just
just be absolutely clear you're saying
that kovacs is short of vaccines kovacs
does not have vaccines to distribute at
the moment
yes what we're saying is that for us to
be able to reach
for the corvettes to also be able to
reach uh you know they they they target
there has to be vaccines and currently
there isn't enough vaccines to also to
also um redistribute in low and
middle-income countries okay because of
this stock
understood so what do you think then
when you see richer countries like
germany and the uk giving third jabs
giving booster shots to their elderly
and at-risk populations
yeah and i think it's it's it's quite a
bizarre thing to be quite honest i think
what we saying that governments and
pharmaceutical corporations shouldn't be
planning to administer you know vaccine
shots um until everyone has actually
received um a vaccine you know and we
see
low levels of vaccinations in africa
where less than three percent of the
population have been vaccinated and you
know even
some health workers and very vulnerable
populations haven't even received the
first dose
i absolutely get that um what difference
do you think uh president biden's new
approach his appeals for a global
vaccination campaign he's promised to
double the united states's uh
contributions what difference is that
likely to make
um i think if we're gonna
use the current model of you know a
charity model because you know there has
been some con i mean commitment to say
that they will um uh donate uh vaccines
um to to to to these low and
middle-income countries if we're going
to go with that model honestly that's
not sustainable we need a much more
sustainable approach that would allow
for countries to be able especially
capable manufacturers to be able to
manufacture vaccines so that we can meet
the current demand because at the moment
we don't you know we with the current
approach it's not very sustainable we
and considering that there's a lot of
hoarding it doesn't really help but if
we're going to have an approach that
ensures that we have more manufacturers
more
companies and countries producing that
in itself is actually a model and that's
what we're saying that you know with the
current calls for a trip's waiver um you
know to allow for countries or other
companies to to manufacture that in
itself would be sustainable to ensure
that we meet the demands that we that
we're currently facing
candice ahoma from mets nasa frontier
thank you so much